here in the United States we have what I
would describe as an employer connected
for-profit health insurance system and
there's nothing sort of natural or
obvious about that system we could have
had a different system all along and
actually in his book deadly spin wendell
potter talks about this how I think it
was between World War 1 and World War 2
we were starting to think about maybe
not going in the direction that we went
and maybe going with something more like
a universal or government health care
program like many of our European
counterparts have that was aborted
because it was too similar to what at
the time Germany was doing our enemy at
the time Germany and so we got the
system that we currently have in the
1990s we started seeing these proposals
from right-wing think tanks for what we
ultimately ended up with in Obamacare
which is a mandate that everybody get
insurance but from for-profit private
insurance companies it didn't happen in
the 1990s but eventually it did with
Obamacare so this is really a right-wing
system people like to say Oh Obama's
Obamacare is a government takeover it's
socialism it's communism there's really
nothing communistic or socialistic from
mandating that everybody become
customers of for-profit insurance
companies so to begin with the
Affordable Care Act is pretty damn
right-wing the problem now for Donald
Trump and Republicans is that they
campaigned for over a year on repealing
and replacing Obamacare and made totally
impossible promises about what the end
result would be you saw dozens and
dozens of symbolic votes in the house
under the presidency of Barack Obama to
repeal the Affordable Care Act which
wouldn't have made a difference it was a
waste of time because it wasn't going to
pass the Senate and if it did President
Obama would have vetoed it anyway and
all of a sudden now you've got
Republicans in the White House
controlling the Senate and controlling
the house and they need to make good on
the campaign promise they said they
would repeal the Affordable Care Act
they said everyone will be covered it
will be cheaper for everyone care will
be better and that's proving to be
impossible and it's not been going well
the first
version of the Obamacare replacement the
American Health Care Act according to
the CBO would have seen 24 million
people lose their coverage the next
version from the house would have seen
23 million people lose their health
insurance coverage we now have a scoring
from the Congressional Budget Office of
the Senate version 2 of the American
Health Care Act which would see an
estimated 22 million people lose
coverage some because they would choose
not to have coverage by the removal of
the mandate no doubt but in total we
would see 22 million fewer people
covered so Mitch McConnell said we want
to vote before the fourth of July break
that starts this Friday we now have
learned not going to happen Mitch
McConnell throwing in the towel saying
we've got to go back to the drawing
board we need to make changes we need to
make amendment it's not going to happen
before the fourth of July break and to
be perfectly clear this is not failing
Pat because of Democratic obstruction
this is Republicans who can't get 50
votes together in the Senate and what
does this prove this proves that they
now realize they can't do what was
promised and what it would have real
political implications if they did right
we knew for a long time that it would be
hard for Republicans to get the votes
together because you had people like
Murkowski and Collins opposing it from
the center and then you had people like
Lee and Cruz opposing it from the right
now you have three or four more names
added on to that and they have to get to
50 votes they can only afford to lose
two it's not even close right now and
Donald Trump held a meeting yesterday
with a bunch of senators and that this
was before it was announced there just
isn't going to be a vote it's just not
going to happen this week he also
tweeted about this saying quote some of
the fake news media likes to say that I
am not totally engaged in health care
wrong I know the subject well and want
victory for us for the u.s. it's almost
worse that Trump is admitting that he's
heavily involved because it's been such
a failure I would want to hide the fact
that I've been involved with this if I
were Trump blame Republicans and
Republicans alone or blame Democrats for
obstruction like he's been doing
although it makes no sense
it can only get worse if you move to the
right
you can't possibly start with Obamacare
and move to the right
giving the for-profit companies more
freedom to raise prices etc and do all
the things you promised right think
about it if you let insurance companies
charge more
some people will no longer be able to
afford insurance they're going to get
cut off from health care you have these
Obamacare subsidies if you reduce the
Obamacare subsidies as the new version
of the Senate bill wants to do then some
people aren't going to be able to afford
insurance they are going to lose care
you're breaking the promise that Donald
Trump made you could say well we'll let
companies keep costs the same for most
people by charging people with
pre-existing conditions more well then
those people won't be able to afford
care and some of those people are going
to die statistically speaking you can't
move to the right and keep cost the same
or lower while keeping coverage the same
or higher you can't but here's the thing
I want people to understand that this
isn't over right now Republicans are
going to make some changes they'll
probably get a slightly better scoring
from the CBO and they're going to try
again so now is when you've got to
contact your Senators and your members
of the house right exactly and people
have to understand that there is an
alternative to the Affordable Care Act
but the sensible one is not to move to
the right we have you just bill has a
seventeen percent approval rating how
about we propose something like Medicare
for all single pet single payer well I'm
going to talk a little bit later on in
the show about that in the context of
Bernie Sanders the progressive movement
senator Elizabeth Warren I've got a lot
to say about that and and I think you're
absolutely right Pat that there needs to
be a paradigm shift on the left but
we'll get to that a little bit later